- You guys, like I was
talking about before,
you have such intense scenes together.
So what did you do to keep things light
while making it so you just
weren't totally depressed?
- I think I binged every
season of Sex and the City
(Kelly laughing)
and the movies.
- You went opposite.
- Yeah, I got through all of
them, and then I finished it,
and I still had like three
weeks left of shooting.
So I was like, "What am I
gonna do?" But yeah, that-
- 'Cause y'all shoot this
during, like, Covid time?
So you were, like, alone?
- Yeah, I was completely alone,
and most of the time I was
just interacting with anybody
it was on set, and usually
screaming at Brendan.
- (laughs) Those were our scenes.
The movie is really about, though,
being honest with, and not
running from, ourselves.
And there's a line that's
repeated from an essay
on "Moby Dick."
"I felt saddest of all when
I read the boring chapters
that were only descriptions
of whales because I knew
that the author was just trying to save us
from his own sad story
just for a little while."
It's, like, the saddest line ever,
but also rings very true
for a lot of people,
and it hits home.
So, like, Brendan, what
have you had to learn
to embrace about yourself?
Like, did not working
for a while change you?
- In a way. I'll get there in a sec.
Just to put context to what you read,
that's from the essay that
Sadie's character Ellie
has written when she's
about eight years old.
And because Charlie is an English teacher
he believes this to be the best essay
he's ever read because
of how honest it is.
And he implores his students,
who he teaches online,
with the camera turned off,
to do the same just give him
something honest to read.
And once she does,
it's almost as if it sets
their relationship free.
- Yeah. I love that. I
didn't wanna spoiler alert,
that's why I didn't say who did it.
But you did.
(audience and Sadie laughing)
I literally asked my executive
producer, I was like,
"Am I allowed to say it's her
or will that spoil anything?"
- Brendan, you gave it away.
- But Brendan did it, not me.
Um, so it's, like, an interesting thing.
You go through the film,
and it's something that you prize,
and then you find out why.
And I think, like, what you
just said about it, too,
towards the end, I'm glad you said it
because it is freeing to be
honest even, like, if you're sad
or even if-
That's real, like, we get sad.
We go through things,
and it's a real thing,
and a raw thing to be.
If you're gonna be a writer,
and you're gonna write something,
might as well be pure
right? So I agree with that.
(audience applauding)
But Brendan, you got a six
minute standing ovation
when "The Whale" premiered
at the Venice Film Festival.
How did that feel?
I mean, you seemed so overwhelmed.
Yeah.
- Correct!
- Yeah. It had to be just so overwhelming,
and that role is so important.
- Really affirmed, surprised, astonished,
and a little bit Italian.
(audience, Sadie, and Kelly laughing)
- What? Oh my god, you're
always welcome on this show.
(audience cheering)
(Sadie clapping)
Oh, what, instead of asking him
because he was obviously exquisite,
what was it like to watch?
'Cause you've been shooting
this movie with him
and going through these very
intense scenes, like you said,
you're like always yelling
at him and you're, you know,
very angry. Like, what was
it like to watch that happen?
- I was a little nervous.
That was the first time we'd
showed it to an audience.
So I think they were all a little relieved
that they were clapping and standing and-
- [Kelly] Responded so-
- [Sadie] Responded, yeah.
- Oh, that's intense.
I didn't realize it was the first time.
- Yeah, it's very nerve-racking,
but it turned out well.
- Oh, God,
I would never want to experience
that for the first time
in front of a ton of people. That's brave.
So Brendan, before this movie
do you remember the last
trophy you ever won?
Like the last thing?
- I remember one of the very first times.
- What?
I was in grade four,
and I knew there was a banquet coming up,
and I was excited because
the season had ended,
and they were handing
out awards and prizes.
And I was waiting for them to
call my name, and they did!
It was for the peewee bowling league.
(Kelly and audience laughing)
(audience, Sadie, and Kelly clapping)
- Yes!
I love bowling.
- I think it was probably
a participation trophy,
and they did misspell my name on it.
I think it said like Borton
Kushner or something like that.
(audience and Sadie laughing)
- Oh that's so sad.
- But you know what,
It was my bowling trophy,
and I was very proud of it.
(audience and Sadie clapping)
- So, okay, so the
difference, I do have to say,
and maybe you remember
this, you were young 10,
but in Texas they don't give
you participation ribbons.
You either win or lose.
It's like, no, but I think
it so you got sad about it
'cause we're here in LA.
I know, but I'm just saying
I think it's important
to learn how to lose.
- [Brendan] Does anyone know
what that means?
- What did you say?
- I said it was for a high game handicap,
and to this day I still
don't know what that means.
(audience and Kelly laughing)
- I don't know what that means either,
but I don't think it's good. I don't know.
Okay. Do you still have that trophy?
I was wondering if we could see it.
- Sadly, no. It's lost
to the sands of time.
- Oh, that's such a bummer.
Well, we heard about
the lost bowling trophy,
so we sent you a little gift.
It should be there.
So go ahead and open it.
- What?
- Yep.
(audience cheering)
(Sadie clapping)
- Here?
- Yep.
Yes. Look at that! Look at that!
(clapping) It's about
to get real exciting.
- No way!
(audience cheering)
- Brian Fusher.
(audience, Sadie, and Kelly clapping)
We just kinda made up a name
'cause we know it didn't
say yours anyway. (laughs)
- And I'd like to thank
the makers of bowling balls
and bowling pins.
And the wax that makes the aisle so shiny.
The shoes! I love you smelly
shoes that are rented!
- Oh, it says Brian Fusher.
So we engraved it for you.
Do you mind reading it?
- "Just give me something (beep) honest."
(audience and Kelly clapping)
(Kelly and Sadie laughing)
- Thank you!
Thank you, Brendan!